Buenas tardes Así es pues estoy aquí en
la plaza de chat lesto es el pleno
centro de la capital francesa es la
mitad digamos del recorrido de esta
manifestación que ha de terminar en la
Plaza de la bastilla de decirles que
cuando salió esta marcha desde ópera más
temprano Desde allí les estuvimos
transmitiendo Pues esta marcha pasó muy
cerca por el frente de el consejo
constitucional y allí se presentaron
algunos momentos de tensión con algunos
manifestantes que hubo lanzamiento de
piedras y de botellas sobre la policía
porque lo cierto Es que ese consejo
constitucional está completamente
digamos casi que blindado por a la
policía y sobre todo por la policía
antimotines sin embargo pues está
manifestación aquí en la capital se ha
venido desarrollando más bien en total
la tranquilidad han quemado una que otra
caneca de basura algo digamos ya usual
acostumbrado Pero bueno Tendremos que
esperar por lo menos un poco ya que
caiga la tarde aquí en París para saber
exactamente Cuál fue la participación
total aquí en la capital y por supuesto
en todo el país se estiman entre unas
400.000 a 600.000 personas que saldrían
o habrán salido a manifestar este día
jueves en toda Francia